ازمه الحدود بين البلدين التي تفجرت اخيرا
بين ايران وافغانستان اعادت خلافا قديما
يعود الى السبعينيات خلاف مائي يدور حول
تقسم البلدين نهر هيلماند نهر هيلماند يعد
اطول نهر في افغانستان واهم مورد للماء
لكل من كابول وطهران باعتباره شريانا
رئيسيا تعتمد عليه حياه السكان على الحدود
الافغانيه الايرانيه يبلغ طوله الف ومئه
وخمسين كيلو مترا وهو ينبع من جبال
هندوكوش في الشمال الشرقي من افغانستان ثم
يصب في بحيره هامون في الاراضي الايرانيه
من اهم روافد من اهم روافده نهر الغنداب
وايضا نهر تارناك هنا يجب ان نعرف بان
النهر يدخل ايران مرورا بمنطقه سيستان
وبلوشيستان قبل ان يصل الى مصبه في
البحيره وهو واحد من بين انهار تشترك فيها
افغانستان مع جيرانها مثل نهر امو المشترك
مع تاجكستان اوزباكستان وتركمانستان
الحكومه الافغانيه المتعاقبه حرصت على
بناء عدد من السدود على نهر هيلماند بهدف
تخزين المياه وزياده توليد الطاقه
الكهرومائيه منها سد كاجاكي وسد كمال خان
الذي يقع في الجنوب الغربي ولتنظيم
التوزيع العادل لمياه النهر وقع البلدان
اتفاقيه قديمه قبل خمسين عاما الاتفاقيه
تكفل لطهران الحصول على 26 مترا مكعبا من
المياه في الثانيه الواحده وعلى هذا
الاساس يتدفق الى ايران سنويا 820 مليون
متر مكعب من المياه القادمه من افغانستان
غير ان الاتفاقيه لم تحل الخلافه بين
الجانبين طهران ترى بان السدود الافغانيه
تحول دون تدفق المياه اراضيها بالشكل
الكافي منذ ان اعلنت الحكومه الافغانيه
استكمال قرار بناء السدود واداره المياه
لمعالجه ازمه الجفاف مشيره الى انها خاسره
العامه الماضي نحو اربعه ملايين متر مكعب
من المياه القادمه من افغانستان غير ان
طالبان عزت سبب تراجع تدفق المياه لايران
الى قله هطول الامطار افغانستان تحصل على
57 مليار متر مكعب من متوسط مياه الانهار
السنوي لكنها لا تستهلك سوى 30% من هذه
الكميه اذا قضيه الانهار الحدوديه ورفع
العوائق امام حلها هما الرهان الرئيسي
والذي تراه طهران معيارا مهما بالنسبه
لتطور العلاقات بين البلدين لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاع جاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات